I mentioned Texas I mentioned beta or
work got destroyed and usually I say
okay let's take the high road let's not
rub it in anybody's face but Beto he
just bothers me okay and so Alex Stein
who has become one of the absolute top
trolls in America and he's just he just
seems you know completely uh Unleashed
and like a dog with a bone and he I had
him on the show you know he just does
things that are so vulgar and mean and
you just need to say I could never do
that well anyway he did it to baitone it
was very very funny
do you feel guilty about the millions of
dollars you wasted on your campaign beta
why do you want to protect Trey's
children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you feel guilty about the money you
wasting how are you going to protect
trans kids by cutting off their genitals
how does that protect trans kids beta
beta how does that protect trans kids
[Applause]
how are you protecting trans kids by
cutting off their genitals
how many more losses are you gonna take
you're gonna where's your campaign money
going
beta are you pointing out to this
failure are you gonna quit after you
fail today
do you feel guilty that you're a loser
later
[Applause]
do you feel like a loser Beto
you know the the election night it was a
little bit I just feel like I'm getting
a little sick you know I just I was so
excited I thought I was going to be
popping champagne and I'm feeling just a
little down you know like I've got oh
I'm just just a little worn down in that
video of Alex Stein just yelling at Beto
and calling him a loser and asking if he
feels bad for wasting millions of
dollars on another failed campaign it's
just like a nice bowl of chicken soup
you know it's just like a nice warm
broth I just think
and then people are trying to pull Alex
Stein away and pull you know kind of hit
him in the head with with signs but he's
just kind of a big belligerent madman
and so he doesn't even care he just
doesn't just a dog with a bone doesn't
even stop beta you're a loser you want
to chop off kids genitals why are you
such a loser beta so it was a nice after
the kind of headache and aches and pains
of election night kind of set in that's
just a nice little
nice little bit of chicken soup right
now head on over to establishtitles.com
Knowles established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of Lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in Scotland okay I had this
problem where I thought I'm just not
getting the respect that is due to me
okay people when they come up to me
they'd say hey Michael
hey Mr note mister
I want to be referred to as a lard or a
lord okay there is this uh wonderful
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as Lords and Ladies well in
your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are a couple
packs because you don't want to let your
wife you know just be some strumpet
you're a Lord and then she's just some
chick on the street so you want her to
be a lady as well established titles
told me that the first 200 people to
purchase a title pack using my exclusive
link will receive a plot within walking
distance of mine depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or a lady
we can begin to build our own kingdom
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now and if you use
code Knowles at checkout you will get an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com Knowles to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
it was a bit of a rough
night and it's it's hard to figure out
exactly what the takeaway is now I will
say
I try not to make predictions you'll
notice I usually do not make these firm
predictions about election night in fact
inasmuch as I did make predictions I
said You know guys I actually don't
think we're going to really win
Pennsylvania I don't think mastriano is
going to win I don't think John Federman
is or I rather I don't think Dr Oz is
going to beat fetterman I think
fetterman's going to be an upset I did
predict that Sean Patrick Maloney the
head of the D Triple C would lose in New
York's 17th congressional district he
would lose to the Republican Mike Lawler
I was right about that one too so I made
I made very
particular predictions where I felt
that the evidence was relatively clear I
did not make Grand sweeping predictions
and even other than you know maybe
advertising copy for the election show I
didn't say you know it's guaranteed
we're gonna have a red tsunami I'm gonna
be drinking leftist tears all night I
tempered expectations because I said you
know there's going to be some questions
people have been voting since September
there's lots of there's some not great
candidates out there and uh so I just
think as Drew claven says
you can't predict the future the future
is the future that's that's why it is
the future and so there is this funny
thing that goes on which is that the
pundits and the prognosticators
who make it their job to say I know
exactly what's going to happen on
Election night and they get all the
predictions wrong then the next day they
come out and they tell you precisely why
their predictions precisely why things
happened as they did happen and they
kind of ignore the fact that their
predictions were all wrong that happens
across the aisle and it happens all the
time with political pundits being a
political pundit is never having to say
that you're sorry
especially if you're the kind that just
tries to predict every single race and
so you're going to see a ton of people
today say well this is exactly why the
Republicans didn't do very well and
you're going to see a coincidence here
that the reasons why the Republicans
didn't do very as well as they were
supposed to is going to totally line up
with all of the pundits priors it's it's
going to affirm every premise that the
pundits had going in even if those uh
premises did not result in accurate
predictions for election night and
that's just what happens that's just
politics but but I've got a less popular
but I think more accurate take which is
there are a lot of factors here and you
can't just blame it on the fraud and you
can just blame it on Trump and you can't
just blame it on
early voting and you can't just blame it
on Roe v Wade and you can't just you
can't just
there's a lot going on especially when
you look at two races you look at JD
Vance and Blake Masters
JD Vance and Ohio Black Masters running
for Senate in Arizona
they ran the same campaign they're
basically the same candidate they've got
the same background they've got the same
backers they ran on the same platform
JD wins Blake very very likely will lose
or it's just very unclear at least at
the moment
why is that well Ohio and Arizona are
different that's part of it
there's just a lot there's just a lot in
there and so what what you're going to
see now is the battle over what happened
and the battle over what happened is
nothing more than a proxy for the battle
for 2024. when I say the election is
dead long live the election this is not
the second day of counting the votes of
election day 2022. this is the first day
of the 2024 Republican presidential
primary and so all of the commentary
that you're going to be seeing today is
a facade a thinly veiled facade for a
campaign for one candidate or another in
2024 and because I actually have not
picked a candidate and I'm not endorsing
you know certainly not at this stage in
a presidential primary that's why I am
just trying to present all of these
sides and all of these uh all of these
factors that went into the midterms
last night although I am I am very
interested in hearing from you as well
and what you think happened in what you
were seeing in your polling places I
mean you the listeners to this show
or spread not just all around the
country but all around the world
we know that people all around the world
are watching the American elections as
well uh most of the people here at the
daily wire have coincidentally just been
overseas in Europe or the Middle East
within the past month and we know that
that people overseas everywhere follow
the American elections but especially
for those of you who are listening from
the United States right now what did you
see in your Precinct at your polling
place with your candidate with the with
the Republican Congressional candidate
in your District
some races that we thought we were going
to win my friend Beau Heinz was running
North Carolina he lost Lauren bobert
really really on the ropes Republican
Congressman another friend of mine in
Colorado so what happened what did you
see who and especially as everyone is
just looking to be so vindictive the
next morning
who do you blame let me know you can let
me know on Twitter or in email or
whatever comments and mailbag but you
can especially let me know in the member
block of this show the rest of the show
continues now it is woke Wednesday we've
got an ad from fetterman that my
producers tell me is one that I actually
didn't play I haven't seen this one so I
guess they just want to rub salt in the
wounds of Senator fetterman coming out
uh you don't want to miss this part of
the show if you're not a member click on
the link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]